joining us with reaction is fox news
analyst former white house press
secretary kaylee mcenany
and along with candidate the next
governor the great state of arkansas
sarah sanders uh is with us huckabee
sanders uh i told you dad you're going
to be a better governor than he was he
didn't disagree with me
um good to see you both uh sarah start
with you
i never saw i never saw president trump
get any
that kind of easy press conference today
i never saw president trump lie that
much in that shorter period of time
frankly sean it was hard to watch either
joe biden
doesn't know what's going on or he is
deliberately
misleading the american people whether
it was on immigration
china guns he could not give a clear
answer on anything take immigration for
example
it is absolutely obvious that trump's
border policy was working
and biden's border policy is a complete
and total failure
it's not complicated when you encourage
and even welcome people to come here
illegally they do there is not only a
health crisis
a humanitarian crisis but a national
security crisis at the border
joe biden is failing to even recognize
it exists
much less being willing to deal with it
certainly not going to be transparent
he fumbled all over the place talking
about
uh when he would allow the media in to
see it and it sounds like that's going
to be next to never
because he's not letting them in until
the problem goes away
and they've yet to even recognize or
admit that there is a major crisis at
our border
you look at china his total weakness
on china and they know it and we know it
they don't fear him and they certainly
don't respect him
it's going to be very hard for him to
deal with the big issues of the day
when he can't even get through a basic
friendly press conference with a handful
of reporters at the white house
that he's been prepping for days to do
kaylee back in any true or false
did donald trump ever prepare
for press conferences like this did he
even prepare
at all and is it or is it not true that
donald trump
talked to the press more than anybody
probably in the white house wanted i'll
ask sarah the same question
after you yeah you're right look the
president took great detail on his
scripted remarks that topper and he
would make edits meticulously
uh but no in terms of the q a and back
and forth i maybe had a minute as we
were rushing to the podium i can tell
you something else
president trump didn't do i certainly
did not give him a list of reporters
to call out in order i would tell him
who's in the room and then he
himself would make the decision who to
call on and sometimes i would even say
hey you might not want to call on that
person
today they're really hot on a topic
that's going to be tough and he almost
relished that even more and he sometimes
oftentimes would call on that more
hostile reporter
first uh so it's incredible and just one
last point sean i pulled up one of the
president's press briefings today former
president trump just to get a taste of
what it was like and to bring myself
back the very first question he was
asked in the briefing i pulled up
was why did you lie to the american
people and how will they ever trust you
i could never have envisioned the press
corps asking asking president biden
anything
like that all right kaylee we've got to
start preparing to call
uh sarah governor huck the governor's
yes indeed stop practicing i know
um we're watching your race closely and
we want you to win that race and we
think you will all right thank you both